so this is the modern media for you the
only problem with demonizing men is that
it requires you to talk about men too
much
and that's the Barbie movie for you too
thousands of moms took their daughters
to see this thing over the weekend
and um you know it is a it is a
certainly a wonderful movie to show your
daughter if you want your daughter to be
a vapid man-hating harpy
if that's your great dream for your
daughter then by all means show them
Greta gerwig's Barbie
but this is not actually what most
mothers want for their daughters
so for comparison's sake contrast this
with the general public reaction when a
movie wears its feminist credentials on
its sleeve
take the upcoming Snow White remake for
example we've already seen how they
traded in Snow White for snow Brown
casting a Hispanic woman in the title
role and for whatever reason they
decided that the most inclusive approach
is to take casting opportunities away
from actors with dwarfism by turning the
Seven Dwarves into regular-sized carnies
but they're also changing the whole Arc
and theme of the story to make it more
feminist as this interview with the
Stars revealed watch
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that
I didn't go 1937.
she's not gonna be safe with the prince
and she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in
uh it's not 1937 anymore that's true
more is the pity
now we're not going to focus on the
point that the taller woman there Gal
Gadot is playing the evil queen and the
shorter one is playing Snow White now
remember that in the story The Queen is
supposed to be jealous of Snow White's
Beauty
you know mirror mirror on the wall who's
the fairest one of all and the mirror is
supposed to tell her that it's snow
white so we're supposed to buy that okay
we're supposed to buy that Gal Gadot is
asked who's the fairest one of all and
it's not her it's Rachel zegler
um this is a real problem kind of hard
to pull off in this case as the evil
queen is significantly more attractive
than snow white but you know putting
that aside the point is that the clip
you just heard has been roundly mocked
by nearly everyone
the movie is destined to be a worse flop
than the woke Little Mermaid
bastardization was I mean it's
guaranteed to be a flop
because nobody wants to see a fairy tale
where the Damsel in Distress no longer
needs saving and the central romance has
been replaced with a dreary sermon about
self-empowerment
nobody wants to see Snow White become a
corporate middle manager and Achieve
true happiness by moving into a
two-bedroom condo with her cat
they want to see her get saved by The
Prince and fall in love that's what
people want to see
when you advertise ahead of time that
your film is going to is going to go the
former route rather than the latter
going the feminist route rather than the
Classic route nobody will see it
so feminism has to trick you it has to
smuggle itself in it can't walk in the
front door announcing its arrival
because people will will scream and run
out the back door away from it
well you know I love anything made with
top of the line quality for meat that's
good ranchers the only thing missing is
a pork box well you asked for it and
they delivered good ranchers has just
launched their Prime pork 100 American
pork that is Steakhouse quality this new
pork box comes with bone-in and boneless
pork chops sausage smoked brats and more
plus right now you'll get 30 off with my
code Walsh at goodranchers.com on their
site you can explore their All-American
cuts of prime pork Prime Beef and better
than organic chicken options as well if
you've tried their beef and chicken
before then you know how amazing it is
you have to try this Prime pork at least
once trust me they've got genuinely
great products and top tier customer
service so what are you waiting for
enjoy real meat and real service today
with good ranchers visit
goodranchers.com and use my code Walsh
for 30 off any box that's promo code
Walsh at goodrancers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
buying a new car can be stressful uh
it's a successful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first time buyer
if you have no credit before you walk
into a dealership and spend the entire
day with the crowds stress the potential
you might not even find what you're
looking for you need to check out car
Zing car Zing is completely changing the
way you buy a car online by partnering
with Credit Agencies lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide karzing provides
you with everything you need but four
stepping foot into a dealership once you
find the right card your ideal budget
all you have to do is bring your save
deal voucher with you to the dealership
to finalize your next ride it is so
simple even if you're not in the market
for a new car check out cars anyway
karzing's online window shopping
experience goes beyond mere images you
can dive deep into each vehicle
specifications features and performance
capabilities zoom in on the
craftsmanship of the Interior Marvel at
The Cutting Edge technology and admire
the meticulous attention to detail that
sets these automobiles apart from all
the rest carsing also helps make the
experience faster cheaper and less
stressful visit carzing.com Walsh today
find the best deals near you that's
carzing.com Walsh
that's because despite what snow Brown
claims nearly all women innately desire
a man to protect them and provide for
them that's what almost all women want
women want to be swept off their feet by
Prince Charming that's that's why these
stories have lived on for centuries and
resonated with each new generation
the feminist fairy tale resonates with
no one
it's a vision of what feminism wants
women to do and and what it wants women
to think and what it wants women to want
but it will always ring false because it
is false
now
that's not to say that feminism hasn't
won many disciples in the modern world
obviously it has
proven to be a devastating and lethal
Force far deadlier than the bomb at the
center of the other Blockbuster this
weekend
feminism has killed 60 million babies
and that's just the beginning of the
destruction that it has wrought on the
world but it wins adherence through
brainwashing intense and constant
indoctrination especially in public
schools and by playing on a woman's
resentment and hatred and self-pity and
desire to blame others for her problems
you know this can work in the culture
unfortunately it doesn't really work as
a fairy tale because fairy tales are
aspirational and fanciful and whimsical
feminism on the other hand is bass and
vulgar and hateful
and it also doesn't work in marketing
materials for a film based on a beloved
children's toy
that's why they hit it away tucked it
under all the pink and plastic and then
came out with the man-hating
sledgehammer when the audience was
already sitting in the seats
so the only question is whether those
mothers who took their daughters then
you know to see this film did they then
spend the whole ride home explaining why
all that stuff in the movie was wrong
better yet as soon as they saw what was
really happening did they grab their
daughter by the hand and leave the
theater before the movie ended
or were they too obtuse to notice the
toxic feminist message even when it was
delivered with a sledgehammer
or were many of these mothers already
man-hating feminists themselves and so
they didn't see any problem with it
I suspect a mix of all these options has
played out this past weekend but I hope
there were plenty in the first category
and for any parents who hadn't yet taken
their daughters to see this movie but
planned on going in the future
well
now you know better thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts